[upbeat music]
(Speaker)
The Yale Peabody Museum,
I really think is an icon
for the city of New Haven,
for the state of Connecticut
and for New England.
It's where so many people
and I count myself as well,
learned about
the world around us,
understood our
place in the universe.
♪
(Mariana)
Fossil collections
at the Peabody are amazing.
They just are.
But also,
we have a lot of firsts,
and not a lot of museums
can say that.
We have a lot of
what are called holotypes.
So it's the first specimen
ever found
of that dinosaur, for example.
And that is, first of all,
very exciting.
And second,
you start thinking about it
and it's every single other one
that has ever been found
has been described
based on our collection.
One of the key
parts of this whole project
is the Fossil Hall.
Burke Hall is the heart
of the Peabody Museum.
[wrench sound]
Some of the first ever
fossil mounts
are being reworked
to be displayed to,
you know, the next generation
of museum visitors.
(Vanessa)
With regard to our upcoming
renovation due to open in 2024,
we've had the fortune of
working with
Research Casting International
who's based up in
Trenton, Ontario, Canada,
and they're a professional firm
who brings to us expertise
and skill in mounting specimens,
particularly
the very large mounts
that are here at the Peabody.
They helped us
with deinstallation,
removing these large specimens
from their original mount
posture in the hall,
and also with the conservation.
We're working with them
to revise the pose
as well as integrate
new materials
into these mounts to make them
the most complete possible.
The reason
why we want to do this is,
first of all,
we want to update our knowledge.
The science doesn't stop,
and so we want to be updated.
Second, all materials age,
and so I think we came in
at the right time
to do a lot of this work,
a lot of this treatment
and preparation
to prevent any damage
that could have happened
in the future.
[tranquil music]
(Speaker 1)
Trenton, Ontario
is a small town about an hour
and a half east of Toronto.
We're located
on the Bay of Quinte,
which is kind of the gateway
to the Trent-Severn Waterway.
[stream water running]
(Speaker 2)
Very scenic.
A lot of tourists
come here in the summer.
It's away from the sound and
the hub of Toronto, we're like a
nice, quiet community.
(Speaker 1)
It is a bit of a
contrast what we do in here
and what the scenery
is like outside.
It's like a boating
and kind of vacation area
[heavy rock music]
[machine noise]
and then we have heavy
steel work going on
♪
and giant dinosaurs
and all sorts of creatures.
A lot of people are surprised
when they hear
what we do in here.
I don't think anybody realized
what we actually do.
[welder sparking]
♪
We are Research
Casting International.
Right now we're about 50,000
square feet, 40 employees
and we've been in business
35 years.
Companies that do what we do,
you probably
count them on one hand.
Of all the companies
in the world
that do this sort of thing,
we're probably the largest.
(Matt)
For the Yale Peabody project
we're doing
a number of specimens
which are pretty amazing,
like this archelon
we've been looking at
for a long time it's
one of our favorite specimens
and one of mine
specifically is the brontosaur
that we're doing and you know,
having things
that were collected by Marsh
and getting to work on them
are a pretty amazing thing
to be able to do.
It's pretty iconic I think.
It's just because we get to work
on these massive creatures and
the brontosaur itself is,
when I think of a dinosaur,
that's the first dinosaur
I think of and a lot of kids
feel that way.
We're very
excited to work on it.
It's pretty cool work.
[upbeat rock music]
When we start a project,
we do all the cleaning,
conservation, preparation first.
Each person
has their own station
and they work on an individual
component of a specimen.
We usually start off
by cleaning the dinosaur bones
with chemicals like acetone,
ethanol and sometimes alcohol.
So we start by removing
any of the grime or dust
that has been built up
on the specimens
and then sometimes we use an air
scribe to remove old plaster
that's been covering the bones.
There's lots of steps involved,
and then that would go
to the blacksmiths.
[machine noise]
(Brian)
Once the bones
come from the preparators
and they're all cleaned
and consolidated,
they store them
in the storage area in our room
and we move them to our
sandbox as you can see here.
They're supported in the sandbox
and then we start measuring
for an armature.
Obviously, this being a
historically significant fossil,
we have to take a lot of care
to preserve it and preserve all
the numbering and markings on it
and the history behind it.
These armatures
protect the bone.
It also doesn't
destroy any of the fossil.
It's noninvasive,
and you can remove any bone
from the mount that way.
[lift machinery]
beep, beep, beep
After all the armatures
are done,
we build the
support steel for it
and we start building the pose.
So all of these armatures
get welded together
[sound of welder sparks]
into the desired pose.
It's going to look
a lot more dynamic.
It looks more in motion
than it did before.
(Vanessa)
We want the specimens
to be interesting and lifelike,
even though they're static,
and so that can just take
very small changes
in the way that the head
is positioned
or that the tail
is bent and turned.
This is revised by new research
and it's informed
by new collections.
We try to find fossils
and increase the data set
available to us
to study and interpret
how an organism
may have changed through time,
what its paleoenvironment
may have been like,
what its locomotion
may have been like.
[warm relaxing music]
(David)
All of the tremendous science
that's been done over the past
many decades is informing
what we're able to do for this
this next generation of display.
We've got great partners
who are helping us do that.
Working with RCI has been a
really smooth experience for us.
Their approach to their work
is one of the highest standards
when it comes to the materials
and the techniques that they use
and the care that they bring
to our materials.
We as an institution
have entrusted RCI with
our most precious specimens,
and they in return
are really taking this material
to the next level
and presenting it to the world
in such a way
that it will be enjoyed and
learned from for years to come.
Knowing that the work that
I'm doing now is going to be up
for another century.
Is, it's pretty humbling that
I've been given this opportunity
to work on such a historically
significant animal and
it's pretty amazing that
my work is going to outlast me.
I just hope that 90 years
from now,
people like me
and paleontologists
will look at it and be like
they did a good job.
(Peter)
Working on the Yale Peabody
project has been a blessing.
Yeah, it's been a really,
really nice project to work on.
This was the beginning
of paleontology
and these specimens
that we're working on
were the specimens
that started paleontology
on that road.
All the history behind it all,
in my mind, it's just amazing.
♪